[Music]
already okay great hi everyone I'm Peter
Van Valkenburg
I'm from coin Center which is a
nonprofit in Washington DC which I'll
explain in a second so this is the end
of a week-long symposium seems like the
right thing to do is to bring a lawyer
up on stage it'll definitely be a change
of pace from from what I understand from
the the schedule hopefully it'll be a
refreshing change of pace for you all
but what I'm gonna talk about is my area
of expertise which is crypto currency
policy and regulation so just as a
roadmap for this session and the next
hour-long session I'm gonna talk about
three primary topics the first thing I'm
gonna do it'll definitely be just the
first probably half of this first hour
is what we call the moral ethical policy
arguments in favor of cryptocurrency
because those often don't get made in a
fully cogent way other than like man
[ __ ] the government or something like
that you know the second thing I want to
talk about is the existing regulations
that already apply to a lot of
activities that people perform or do
using cryptocurrency and I also need to
talk about permissioned versus
permissionless crypto currencies or
digital currencies because that
influences how regulations generally
might apply and because of certain
current events that have happened
recently in the cryptocurrency space and
then the last thing I'll talk about and
this will definitely be in the second
session after the break is some
constitutional law of cryptocurrency
which is many ways more academic because
constitutional questions are sort of far
they're not near they don't always have
immediate impact but they could have
very immediate impact if certain
regulatory evolutions ever came to a
point where we had to make First
Amendment arguments why a regulation is
somehow not not
miscible or Fourth Amendment arguments
why certain data collection violates our
rights to not have warrantless search of
our private information cool so the
first topic that sort of moral ethical
case is I'm gonna go over it it it comes
from a report that we released last
February where we make the case for
electronic cash why these things should
be viewed as socially important so if
that's interesting to you feel free to
find the full report and the third topic
the final topic is also from a report
that that I published the last one was
our executive director on the
constitutional law issues so and these
slides will come back later but I just
wanted to give you a heads up that there
are pretty fully thought-out well
researched and cited research papers
behind the first and the third topics
and the second topic which was the sort
of existing regulations and how they
apply it's sort of just what I do
day to day for the last five years of my
life as a lawyer and the corpus of that
can be found generally on our website
coin Center org because we're nonprofit
and all are all are in for interfacing
with regulators and our advocacy
materials we put out to the public that
brings me to what the heck is coin
Center we didn't pick the name by the
way it's it's it's a kind of a dated
name in the cryptocurrency space back
when everything either had bit or block
or coin in it one of our early donors
insisted that we call it coin Center so
we were kind of stuck with it know if we
died our way it might have been
something like the Institute for
blockchain studies but that's IBS which
reminds people of gastrointestinal
distress so that might not have been
better anyway maybe you shouldn't let
sort of more academic sorts name things
coin Center is a nonprofit that's based
in Washington DC we've been around for
almost exactly five years now and we've
got three full-time attorneys on staff
and we've got support staff and so
that's actually a lot of people to be
working in DC on something as specific
as cryptocurrency policy what we seek to
be is rather like what the Electronic
Frontier Foundation was to the early
internet and continues to be to the
Internet good show of hands if you're
familiar with the e FF seems perfunctory
to ask in Berkeley but so what the e FF
did was they provided a voice to the
aspirations of technologists and people
who use the Internet who wanted either
defense in legal situations or a voice
in Washington DC to determine how policy
around the internet was built out it's a
different voice than say Google's
opinion or Apple's opinion about the
internet quite often they're actually
you know matched pretty well because
often what Google wants is what the FF
wants but obviously there are places
where that match can turn into a
mismatch and so it's good that there's
an organization looking out just for the
internet rather than any corporation
using the internet and their interests
to keep it free and open for everyone to
use so if the e FF is that - the
Internet
we have aspired over our last five years
to be that to open blockchain networks
and by open blockchain networks we
basically mean anything that has a
permissionless consensus mechanism you
know if it's brute work proof of stake
if you can join the network and play a
meaningful role validating the
blockchain and with nothing more than
free software and commodity hardware
that's what we take is our constituency
effectively and we just want to be a
voice in DC that explains these
technologies to people in Congress that
explains these technologies to people in
the regulatory agencies and that just
generally works towards good policy know
we're funded by generous donations from
people in the space about half of our
funding until this most recent year came
from individuals some of them are not
anonymous one of them is Alex Marcos who
was a he's a Bitcoin core developer
there's several you know and the other
half comes from companies building in
the space but they don't get a seat at
the table you have to take my word for
it they don't get a say in our agenda
we set our mission which is to defend
the freedom to innovate using these
technologies and they see our work and
if they want to support us they continue
to support us and that's what we do
pretty self-explanatory and a big part
of this is briefings and testimony
before Congress and that's my segue into
this first topic which is the case for
electronic cash because last February we
decided we wanted to do a briefing for
congressional staff in the House of
Representatives that was curious about
the technology here's a short video at
that demo so it's not the most exciting
demo I've always joke with I have a
friend that actually works in drone
policy and he gets to take staffers out
and show them like an awesome drone and
let the staffer pilot it much more fun
than a candy machine but at the same
time it's a demo and for a long time we
had no demos it was if you wanted to
explain crypto currency to a member of
Congress you'd open up a laptop in front
of them and say hey look at this it
looks just like online banking but I
swear the stuff going on behind the
website is way cooler just trust me and
so actually having like a physical
object in a room and doing a payment
from one device to another for us was a
step in the right direction of making
this more real and more tangible
specifically this transaction I think is
important to look at because what's
going on here is it's a we're using the
Lightning Network in this case but we've
done demos with the theory and we've
done demos with just regular old Bitcoin
transactions but what's happening here
is Jerry my boss has a phone that has a
Lightning enabled wallet in it that's
already funded with a certain amount of
Bitcoin and this candy machine which
I'll tell a little bit more about in the
next few slides also has a Lightning
enabled wallet and so when Jerry pays
the candy machine through the QR code
that's displayed on the screen it's
really a peer-to-peer transaction money
is going straight from where it was
fully in Jerry's control on his phone to
where it now is for the candy right on
the candy machine and at no point in
this person-to-person transaction is
there an intermediary in the middle who
you have to trust at least that's the
premise of these protocols there's no
one who necessarily can walk away with
the funds that's right it doesn't it
doesn't and that's a limitation because
it's also going to be harder than Apple
pay and so hopefully the next few slides
will help you understand why we're
excited about this which would not be
very exciting and how we basically make
those policy arguments why this is
technology worth allowing to continue to
flourish
the point is it works like cash so Apple
pay seems like it works like cash you're
there and someone wanted to be paid and
you just put your credit card down in
the NFC chip and it talks to the
point-of-sale device but really we know
that that's not cash at all an Apple pay
transaction whether it's a Apple credit
card or whether it's whatever is
intermediated there's usually several
intermediaries involved and if it's a
credit card transaction it's not even
settlement it's just a pull
authorization it's just basically me
giving permission to the merchant to
then go pull funds out of my bank
account and that settlement will happen
later but of course it's not exactly
like cash it's electronic cash it's
digital cash because we're actually
doing it with a phone paying a computer
okay so this case the Arduino that's
inside the candy machine and that's
pretty revolutionary because there's no
other form of cash that works remotely
you know a cash transaction always has
to happen person-to-person explain
weaker interesting I guess there's
institutions around all money right so
it's important not to oversell these
things and there are institutions of
people running lightning nodes or not
running lightning nodes and there are
institutions of banks and the Federal
Reserve and yes about settling it out
yeah no sure
and so what we want to explain with this
kind of a demo is that while imperfect
because these technologies are still new
and still being refined this simple
transaction tells us some important
things about these three topics they
tell us important things about
innovation and interoperability about
efficiency and scale within an economy
and the big one which will be most of
this first part of the presentation is
tells us some things about privacy and
autonomy so innovation and then
interoperability this will be probably
very familiar argument to anyone who's
you know read about cryptocurrency who's
been interested in cryptocurrency or
open blockchain networks it's the story
of basically we're gonna do two trusted
financial institutions what the internet
did two trusted lines of communication
or intermediaries and communications so
in the old world we had a select few
ways of getting a message across the
world it could be broadcast as
television or radio it could be put into
newspapers and what was revolutionary
about tcp/ip as a protocol is that it
basically removed any necessary
middleman there's several different ISPs
you just need to have competency and
writing for the protocol and then you
can send a message to the protocol and
it also made the type of communication
you're choosing to send irrelevant
you're just sending bits so if you want
to use the airwaves you have to do it in
the form of a TV program you can't send
a website over the television
broadcasting if you want to write an
article it has to be in the format of a
typical newspaper article whereas with
tcp/ip of course is a sort of purpose
agnostic lower-level protocol you can
build smtp on top of it and you can send
basically messages that resolve to
something more like mail or you can
build the web on top of it and have
interactive web sites or without
permission you could start sort of
building something on top of tcp/ip like
VoIP and have voice over the internet
and that's now how of course all phones
work or if you want to build hardware
that interacts with this protocol for
any particular set of unique and
idiosyncratic purp
like Steve Jobs when he had the vision
of the iPhone you don't need permission
to build that you just need to make it
compatible with tcp/ip similarly with
anything that people don't want to build
on top of that hardware like apps on
phones and things like that so this
evolution in how we communicate is I
think pretty widely and reasonably
regarded as sort of the dynamism of the
90s and 2000's in the tech economy this
was a this was a good revolution
generally speaking we're starting to see
aftershocks of it that maybe we don't
like so much but the internet was a
force for job growth was a force for
innovation and so with open blockchain
networks what we say is that we want to
take the remaining centralized systems
out there and create free and open
peer-to-peer alternatives so here's
another set of sort of legacy businesses
and they do things more with payments
and with trusted Ledger's and data
structures if you will how can we turn
their back ends into basically another
free and open protocol that people can
just build things on top of rather than
having to go through any one of these
particular providers and so bitcoin is
one ether is another there are several
and Bitcoin itself is an open protocol
which is why people were able to design
the Lightning Network as a second layer
protocol on top of Bitcoin even though
they weren't the original Bitcoin
developers some of them might have been
some of them weren't they didn't need
permission to build this and Bitcoin no
one needed permission to build Bitcoin
that's just software that's some strange
person released in 2008 2009 and our
candy machine is one example of
something you can just without
permission build on top of the Lightning
Network and this is the person who built
it this is David nesic he's a strange
guy who lives in Switzerland who started
posting on Twitter pictures of what he
was building one day and we found him on
Twitter and reached out to him and said
hey David that's awesome you're building
a Lightning Network enabled candy
machine could we have one to show
Congress and he was immediately yes
absolutely we said we'll pay you it's
like no no no here it's a gift it was
kind of awkward for him because he was
traveling to the US and he was going to
New York not DC
so there was like a weird lightening
enabled candy machine hand off that
happened in New York and then one of us
had to go up and get it was a little
weird but it happened we got it and
what's cool about the story is David
didn't have to get you know permission
to build this thing he didn't have to
open an account with a bank in order to
make it payment enabled he doesn't need
to have a merchant account with a credit
card issuer all he has to do is use the
open spec of the Lightning Network
protocol software and put it in the
right way onto commodity hardware it was
an Arduino and some other circuit boards
that he got off of Amazon and then he
matched it with one of these like it's
usually like a press the button and the
candy comes out he just rewired it so
now it's I think it's a signal from the
Arduino that the Lightning wallet has
been paid give the candy so
permissionless innovation is this you
know is this a real sign of like
progress it's a little silly it's a
candy machine but there's all kinds of
things that we might want to have
payment enabled and maybe it would be
great if you could payment enable
something without having to go through
one of several banks or one of several
intermediaries for example Wi-Fi routers
be great if those things were payment
enabled so we could do micro
transactions so when we move from one
Wi-Fi hotspot to another the handoff is
seamless etc etc so efficiency in scale
what is this little transaction as a
demo tell us about efficiency in scale
well traditional payments are still
fundamentally analog you know any
particular bank or financial institution
might have internal processes that are
digital I mean they're gonna keep track
of their accounts probably on a computer
I'd wager but when you want to pay
somebody who doesn't have the same Bank
as you which is most of the time for
most of us the processes of settling
accounts between multiple financial
institutions are still regrettably very
analog and there usually are going to be
multiple institutions in between so even
when you make a credit card transaction
this still happens in the back end
whether it's ACH or Swift or Fed
or any of these several payment
protocols that exist in the legacy
financial system accounts need to be
reconciled between at least two
financial institutions the person paying
and the person being paid and probably
intermediary financial institutions like
the correspondent banking system and
this takes of course three maybe two now
business days there's some pushes at the
Fed and in the UK towards faster
real-time gross settlement things like
that but it's still very slow despite
the fact that we've for a long time now
been able to send text messages
instantaneously and so this is nothing
revolutionary to you guys because you've
been talking the whole week about
consensus and and state replication but
let's just take these siloed data
structures and turn them into one single
data structure let's share it amongst
all the participants on a particular
network and let's have them reach the
process of agreement in order to add new
transactions to the ledger that's better
right in theory then several siloed data
bases at different financial
institutions in order to do payments and
the Lightning Network is a protocol
built on top of Bitcoin to allow Bitcoin
which natively only enables about seven
transactions per second because of the
cap on the block size to possibly have
many more transactions per second
potentially millions of transactions per
second with almost no fees and so this
transaction we made where we paid the
candy machine it's important to point
out that we had to load the Lightning
wallet which was a normal Bitcoin
transaction and if the lightning candy
machine ever needed to dispose of its
funds to someone off the Lightning
Network they'd have to close the channel
and pay someone else but just the actual
transaction between the already loaded
lightning wallet and the candy machine
this was the fee that our Lightning
wallet recommended we pay in order to
make the transaction go through the
transaction was a point zero nine or 0.9
cent transaction per candy which we
chose as a number because it's fun
because you can't even make that payment
using physical cash unless you're going
to divide pennies up into tenths so to
put that into scale that's one two
hundred and fiftieth of a penny
means you could have 250 payments to the
candy machine and still only pay a cent
in fees at least as the Lightning
Network was functioning that day
absolutely and that's next so remember I
said the thing that makes legacy
payments inefficient is the part where
where you want to pay someone who has a
different financial institution than you
which is most of the people most of the
time but there are parts of the world
where almost like if the Fed was doing
all payments in the u.s. almost all of
the population has the same financial
institution or financial enabled app as
almost everyone else in the local local
region so I'm picking on Shanghai almost
everyone in Shanghai now has Olly pay on
their phones and almost everyone in
Shanghai also now has WeChat on their
phones which does payments and that
means that almost everyone in Shanghai
which is a good deal of people can pay
almost anybody and it only goes through
one of these two centralized
intermediaries so of course efficiency
wise you can't beat this this is one
database that they control and two
numbers being changed on it
it's costless or is it costless and sort
of this is the big question are there
hidden costs are there societal costs
that we would want to worry about
especially if we were in the business of
making policy and I think yes and these
are costs measured in loss of privacy or
loss of personal autonomy so if you've
been to China lately you've noticed that
people are using WeChat now I pay for
almost all transactions this is somebody
paying for lunch this is a fruit stand
you can buy coconuts using WeChat this
is somebody who's performing their
musician and they're getting tips on I
think that's a leap a
it's not a protest almost by definition
this is the place where the picture was
taken this is a bicycle you can rent
using WeChat or Ali pay this is someone
paying for medical services you're
getting the point at this point this is
a library
where you can check out books from a
robot and pay without dealing with
people just using all I pay or WeChat
and so the problem with this in my
opinion is that this means that Ali pay
always knows where you are what you read
if you're sick and so does the Chinese
government and this is not me being
conspiratorial this is not me being like
jingoistic Lee American and anti Chinese
this is just published fact alley pay
has been very clear and so as we checked
that they're happy to share any and all
of their payments information with the
Communist Party of China and the Chinese
government has been very clear with what
they intend to do with this now mountain
of payments data they want to raid all
their citizens they want to give them a
social credit score which is kind of
like a credit score but would also
basically make judgments about what you
bought
what transactions you've engaged in
whether you paid your taxes all these
other things not just your likelihood to
repay your mortgage or whatever and
there's no opt out option this is from
LA Times article and they're right
there's no opt-out option because if you
want to pay somebody in China you're
going to use these services and they're
going to share your data and the data
will go into your score you might say
way you could use cash physical cash but
physical cash is disappearing in China
if you pay using local Chinese currency
you'll often be identified as an
outsider which is kind of ironic because
it's Chinese currency but you'll be
identified as an outsider for using
paper money rather than these systems
that seem so efficient so easy and this
is from the alley pay technical director
they basically were explaining you know
how are you gonna make these judgments
about social credit score they said
someone who plays video games all the
time is probably idle someone who's
buying diapers is probably responsible
so maybe they'll have a higher score I
don't know
do you think that technically we could
have anonymize centralized - no I think
you're right I don't know if China would
let them operate in their jurisdiction
the like visa charges 3% because they
would be stupid if they did yeah that's
right and you know if you're balking at
my sort of government scepticism which
is a more libertarian concern I
completely agree I mean that's just one
concern another one is a more
traditionally liberal or progressive
concern which is we should also be
skeptical of the large corporations and
what they choose to do with the data
whether or not they share it with
government or whether they choose to
keep it private but basically use their
monopoly power to extract rents from
people who pay my point isn't so much
that the Chinese government is evil I
don't think it is or that Ali pay or
WeChat are evil or good I'm not I'm not
sure well the Chinese government has
done some things that I do think are
probably evil actually so let me walk
that back primarily to do with the
weekers in the West and probably several
things that I'm completely unaware of
but my point is that there's a weakness
in these payment systems and it's not a
weakness about efficiency just like you
said because actually this is the most
efficient way to do payments by far it's
a weakness measured in giving up your
autonomy and your privacy to someone in
the middle who's got a lot of power over
you as a human being
and so what happens if your social
credit score goes too low slower
internet speeds this wasn't speculate
speculation either this was also from
sources within the Chinese government
all within the company's restricted
access to restaurants nightclubs golf
courses the removal of the right to
travel freely abroad and already in
China over a million people have lost
the so-called privilege of taking
high-speed rail or traveling on planes
either domestically or internationally
that's a lot of people I can give you a
source for the ban on high-speed rail
travel for over a million people
it's it's over a million at least as
reported by I can't remember which Human
Rights Watch organization it was they
might be a bio source I don't know and
so this is another aspect of this less
to do with privacy more to do with
autonomy if there's one company in the
middle they can also enforce sanctions
against the population so if your score
falls too low a good way to enforce that
sort of guilt if having a low score is
actually guilt would be to go to a lipe
or WeChat as a corporation and say you
should stop processing transactions for
this person and we see this we see this
in a more benign way in the US if you
there was somebody who put thanks for
the Cuban sandwich in the memo field of
their venmo payment and their account
was locked temporarily because Cuba is
on the sanctions list this is a silly
example but this happens all the time
sudden way you can't use your account
because there's questions of fraud or
impropriety or violation of laws there's
nothing you can do about it you have to
go to the payment provider and tell them
to unlock your account and as I said if
physical cash is disappearing as it
really is having your financial accounts
locked really does mean you just can't
participate in economic life until they
get unlocked
I can imagine lots of cases where
there's a reasonable national security
rationale for breaking encryption now
does that mean we should I know I'm just
trying to be a little provocative in
that you know we build these systems and
then the vulnerabilities that they have
or the the nature their architecture can
either be exploited for good or for bad
and there's always good reasons to
exploit sort of weaknesses in their
technical architecture as long as the
government doing that exploitation is
doing the right thing I guess my point
is we should be building systems that
just don't have those weaknesses
but that's a larger metaphysical and
philosophical conversation about
what-what you worry about in the world
do you worry about the abuse of
centralized power or do you worry about
anarchy but those laws don't agree so
nonono so like if we build a payment
protocol should it be compliant with the
Chinese dictates as to who should be
paid or with the European dictates which
have now started to diverge strongly
from the American dictates because they
want to trade with Iran and we want to
just keep sanctioning Iran whose laws
currency that depends on finite resource
which was a gold standard and we got
away from the gold standard because it
doesn't let us increase and decrease the
amount of money they don't allow the Fed
to be paying us how are we envision a
defense going out and letting a bit go
and control the economy what is know and
see our organization I mean there are
plenty people who would love that
I'm not one of them I just want there to
be censorship resistant and private
payment protocols and then are they
gonna replace national currencies no I
don't think so
I just think that's at least not anytime
soon and yeah you're right if they did
and if they were commodity based or you
know like gold or Bitcoin there would be
macroeconomic implications we'd finally
have a good laboratory to find out
whether Keynes was right or whether you
know the the more classical economists
were right about you know how you
stimulate the economy and you know what
is inflation and all that but that's a
whole nother topic I think I just think
there should be a payment rail that
doesn't go through Barclays by necessity
that's the EU boys um there's a
difference between paying for candy and
sending 3 trillion dollars in cash right
so there's or in your view there's no
difference between paying for candy and
moving three trillion dollars well
there's obviously a difference and then
I guess the question is we need to talk
about how we design the ability to
transfer things right so how do you
build a protocol that discriminates and
who gets to choose right yeah no I mean
we've moved quickly into the realm of
sort of deep philosophical prejudices
and that's that's fun but I think this
is just worth sharing this might not be
the this has all kinds of problems
because yeah you could fund a terrorist
attack using Bitcoin I think that's
that's an interesting way to do that
sort of discrimination and and to argue
against myself earlier when I made maybe
the false equivalency to encryption
there's no way to judge what the
plaintext is from the ciphertext so
there wouldn't be a way to mechanically
or mechanistically only enforce the
decryption that we want you know but
maybe we could actually force the
censorship or non privacy of certain
payments that we think are just too big
it is possible whereas the encryption
stuff would not be possible it's a good
point
we have to deal with which means you
probably don't want the one size it's
all yes this kind of this does though
get into the question of key escrow with
encryption I think that's absolutely
right and and you know our point is that
this debate isn't being had to the
fullest because everyone seems to think
that bitcoin is the revolution that's
changing the world when in reality the
network financial system is the
revolution that changed the world so a
hundred years ago no one knows who you
pay there's no records of that you go to
the bank occasionally and you take out
cash and then all your day-to-day
transactions are made using cash which
leaves no record
unlike Bitcoin which actually has an
audible record and then suddenly
everything is being done using bank
cards and now apps on phones and now
there is a massive amalgamation of data
and right now it's all poorly secured
and basically public you know there are
efforts to keep it private within
financial institutions and they get
hacked all the time and these systems
are bad and we could as was suggested
maybe push centralized payment
processors to be better with privacy or
we can talk about building peer-to-peer
alternatives but that debates not being
had because I think everyone thinks that
the world we're in now is somehow not
very novel when in reality it's
radically different this use of WeChat
nellie pay in China is an incredible
tool for totalitarians it's also an
incredible tool for people you know it's
great but it's also a liability I think
that's the point that we want to get
across ultimately Reacher is an app on a
phone whatever someone was using there
is an app that they downloaded on my
phone that interfaces is likely so I
mean to some extent centralization is is
a natural phenomenon we've seen it
happen with every decentralized
technology that's been deployed we've
seen that happen with crypto currencies
so you know I mean these systems it's
it's good obviously to move towards
decentralization and build on these
decentralized backends but the
interfaces into them will become and our
centralized right and so you mean
because like we used I forget the name
of the lightning while app we use
because it auto-updates on an Android or
iOS tavae device and they can sort of
sneak stuff into the code you know so
you don't like the decision they're
making then you do something else but
then it seems like the solution in the
world is just like infinite segmentation
right so like I don't like etherium I'm
you know hard fork and now I have it
here in classic and then I don't like
this latest decision by the developers
so now I'm gonna make my new thing and
you know we're in this like economy
where everything becomes worth something
somehow but it's like yeah I don't know
I don't think that's the only answer
here I think I think it would be an
oversimplification of these new
technologies to say that because there's
a handful of developers that write the
code they're part and parcel the same as
basically JP Morgan's back-end the big
differences being that we don't even
know what JP Morgan's back-end is
because it's proprietary and its
proprietary both in the sense that the
code that they run on their several
servers around the world is not
open-source
it's not published to the public nobody
knows you know what it is it's trade
secret so it might have weaknesses that
we don't know it might do things we
don't know
and the right to participate in
maintaining that back end is one that is
fully controlled by JP Morgan
so contrast that with Bitcoin where
there's code that runs it's been written
by the six hundred contributors or so to
the github repository but we all know
that really it's probably about 15
individuals that did the bulk of the
coding but it's all open source
Sam IT licensed Sam I think there's
repositories apart from github that have
copies of it so it's it's full history
and how its evolved and how it's changed
is there for anybody who's
technologically superior at work and
actually play a role in validating the
blockchain you need just a computer and
the open source code now in order to
play a role adding blocks to the
blockchain you're gonna need a data
center full of commodity hardware that
you can buy but in order to actually
just validate every digital signature
for every transaction going back to 2009
you just need actually a pretty ordinary
high-powered home computer digital
signatures are not computationally
intensive to verify the blockchain is
still measured in gigabytes it's not too
big yet it'll get big what we can do you
know anyway I think there's a
fundamental difference there is it a
silver bullet does it mean that somehow
bitcoin is decentralized in the way that
like actual commodity money is
decentralized like gold like you really
don't have to trust somebody if you can
do an essay of gold I guess you do have
to trust somebody if you do an assay of
gold anyway this is getting pretty
metaphysical again and I do think there
is a fundamental difference is it gonna
solve all the world's problems no but is
it a technology worth allowing to
continue which is always the sort of
looming question that were responding to
because we interface with folks in DC
several of whom would just assume ban
this stuff rather than allow people to
continue writing
code so it seems like the main
distinction you made was that the code
is open source oh and the consensus
mechanism for keeping the block
if it's not convincing to you that's
okay this is the amount of cash that's
still in a lot of Western economies some
and actually just global economies some
countries still very much value cash and
there's a lot of in circulation as
percentage of their GDP in some
countries like Sweden is the most
extreme example people are born and
raised and don't know what their local
hard currency looks like they couldn't
identify it actually because they use
apps all the time to pay for everything
which means they are at the whim of
whoever's providing that app or that
credit card for their privacy and their
their autonomy if you will with with
respect to payments and this is a larger
point that I think doesn't get discussed
enough in legal communities punishing
people by going through private
intermediaries to you know force them to
censor payments for certain users I
don't think it can be easily reconciled
with the rule of law so the rule of law
in our legal tradition is that there's
no punishment without there first having
been a law that was described and then
you have to be found guilty of that you
know criminal statute and then there can
be punishment and the fact of the matter
is at least as we've seen it thus far
when payments censorship is used to
affect policy it's done extra legally
it's done outside of the rule of law
WikiLeaks is an extremely controversial
nonprofit and it doesn't matter if you
love them or hate them at this point the
story I want to tell goes back to when
Chelsea Manning leaked the DOJ cables
- Paul here international assumptions
sanctions probably don't fit in a
classic will come you know comprehension
of the rule of law maybe that'd be a
really good Law Review article I've
never I'm not gonna write it and you
know I'm not gonna go take on sanctions
policy but the question is to whether
like you can tell your whole population
that they're simply not allowed to
financially interact with somebody in
another population ever . it is still a
law it's a law and there's a list that's
published and you wouldn't get in
trouble if well hmm would you get in
trouble if you paid someone who wasn't
on the list but was in a sanctioned
country hey it's an interesting question
you have a world in a different country
and you're sending money funding this
other country would you get in trouble i
mean this is kind of an argument here i
don't understand how you could see it's
not a law I mean this might give a
philosophical becomes like international
law we have more regulations you know
more convex regulator
hopefully they're really really bad
things that are essentially still walk
yeah and I mean if this is interesting
to you I can recommend a rich canon of
literature about the nature of the rule
of law and whether it is essentially a
positivist construction this is what hla
Hart argued or whether it has some
normative features to it that make it
somehow better whether there's like a
morality baked into using the law to do
policy an HLA heart basically said say
what you will about the Nazis that's
basically a summer
what HLA Hart said but they still did a
lot of what they did through law and the
only difference was what the ends of
those laws were otherwise they're not
that different than British law and he
was arguing with a guy named lon Fuller
who wrote a really fascinating book
called the inner morality of law who
said first of all you're wrong
empirically the Nazis actually they used
arbitrary power all the time they did
not do things through law and what do I
mean by law this Islamic channeling lon
fuller well there's these seven
principles that I call the inner
morality of law and these are things
like the law should be clear and
comprehensible it shouldn't be you know
impossible to interpret it should be
announced in advance of any punishment
of the law and there's several others it
should be general so there shouldn't be
laws that say like everyone can do this
except Peter that's not a good law
there's it's it's great literature but
it's beyond the talk I'm sorry I
yeah I brought us to the gut god overall
or not it
Goodwin's World War two and Bitcoin
existed yeah you would think that it's
fine for you to send Bitcoin payments to
you know the Nazi German institution no
I think no and and we don't even have to
do that do I think that somebody should
is it okay for someone to pay Kim is it
someone okay is it let me let me let me
bring this more recent and not related
to Hitler is it okay for someone today
to pay kim jeong-hoon is it okay for
someone in new jersey to pick him kim
jong i'd say no it's not okay is that
they should be probably arrested but
should you build a technology
that stops them before they even had a
chance or do you just find them and
punish them for doing something you
think is wrong that's part of the
question
I think the law is pretty clear about if
you build the technology that interprets
you know given Games's all the means
with your petitions you are liable but
but I think the fundamental point here
and again steering away from very very
sensitive things like aroma juice that
you you know when you're in the
cryptocurrencies face talking about what
governments do within their own nation
it's pretty limited and really by nature
this has international oh yeah very very
very different thing when it comes to
values on what you think is right it's
right which is gonna be silent on this
kind of and it's just a pluralistic so
the law of European nations doesn't
agree with the law of America Asia
doesn't agree like and so it's actually
an anarchy it's Hobbs if you will
there's no single sovereign and so it
sort of collapses into a mess I mean I'd
like to have faith in international law
to resolve hard questions but it's
really just a mess I have the UN as a
central banker it's an idea anyway so my
only thing about WikiLeaks was this
whether you hate them or don't mind them
I don't know if anyone likes them
anymore that's fair
when Chelsea Manning link leaked the
Department of Defense cables to
WikiLeaks which revealed a lot of our
practices in Afghanistan and and around
the world that she thought were worth
leaking immediately you were unable to
donate to WikiLeaks which was a
registered nonprofit in the UK by credit
card you can use Visa MasterCard
American Express you can't use any of
those credit cards to make a donation to
WikiLeaks anymore and this wasn't
because we had the Congress in the US
pass a law that says that you can't
donate to WikiLeaks which probably
wouldn't even be a constitutional law
because we had
First Amendment protections of our right
to support nonprofits that you know
further a cause that we think is just
but there wasn't even an attempt to pass
such a law it's basically some powerful
people within the US government talk to
powerful people within American Express
Visa and MasterCard and said if you're a
patriot you'll stop processing these
transactions so extra legal extra legal
is also dangerous even if you believe
that there's generally benign leaders
that the government isn't trying to do
anything wrong because it doesn't go
through a regularize process that has
sort of oversight it could be
algorithmic like I said if you put cuban
sandwich and your venmo transaction your
account might be locked
they'll unlock it later but these things
happen algorithmically and automatically
this is a woman in China who's being
publicly shamed for jaywalking her face
is being put up on this big billboard in
a big city because they have these
facial recognition cameras on the
crosswalks and if your face appears in
the crosswalk when it says don't walk
your face goes up here and then you're
recorded in a database as a jaywalker
the problem is this woman is not
jaywalking she appeared as an
advertisement on the side of a bus and
the bus is repeatedly in the crosswalk
when it says don't walk now this is all
fun and you know fine and they
apologized and and it all ended up okay
didn't didn't end up on our permanent
record but the fact of the matter is a
lot of things can go wrong when you rely
on these sort of algorithmic enforcement
procedures and when the punishment could
be something like oh well suddenly I
can't engage in economic life anymore
because my apps are all locked from what
I understand she's the CEO of this
company so she probably had no problem
getting that like a race from a record
your average person but your average
person's not on a bus either is that you
know whatever and this is another one
that just I think is alarming and shows
the power of the data that people are
collecting as financial intermediaries
this was a sort of like fun
betta plugin for WeChat that you could
install if you wanted and what it would
do is show you like a Google map style
map of your local locality and put
little people on that map who Oh a lot
of money I don't know what they want
people to do with this information like
you just walk around and like oh not
going to you know buy or sell from you
or maybe they'll shun you I don't know
it's just it's it's very alarming and so
my point it's not an absolutist point
it's just that only digital cash systems
like Bitcoin and aetherium preserve a
free and open alternative that can't be
taken away by even the most corrupt
government or unscrupulous corporation
and so if you think that on balance most
people will use these systems for good
and we can tolerate the evil that people
will use these systems for then it's
good that there's this escape valve it's
good that there's the system that can't
be destroyed by a corrupt government you
know to shut down the Hong Kong protests
or what-have-you
it's good that there's a system that
exists even if the banks want to charge
monopoly rents over all financial
transactions because they've achieved
some sort of market power that's
absolutely true
we don't have tech that solves that yet
I think so maybe we should just say like
instead of can't be taken away there it
is increases the costs of taking it away
pretty radically I mean even even the
idea of say China shutting down the
Bitcoin network by you know seizing the
ASIC boundaries where all the chips are
made and then plugging them in and then
not putting transactions in blocks
anymore would be it's incredibly
expensive even for China but they could
do it yeah they could do it and then
what would we do we just use aetherium
you know or we'd use some other one so
it'd be a whack-a-mole game that's
incredibly costly very quickly what if
an app store just takes away all apps
that provide an interface into a
cryptogram Linux go open-source apps you
know screw the Play Store screw the iOS
you know App Store uh not many but maybe
some human rights activists who use tor
who use PGP
and some criminals to be totally honest
of course it's worth noting being able
to just change the and then you've
bought all these Asics that do
diddly-squat now Congrats you've got a
giant pile of silicon that's useless and
in fact the easiest way for China to
attack Bitcoin was probably from what I
understand be a DDoS attack on the
peer-to-peer network just to stop
messages from moving around rather than
actually trying to do a 51% attack
similar results that's I'm not a not a
sysadmin or a you know a highly
technical person so I don't know but
that sounds right to me okay one thing
that no one has brought up but maybe
it's cuz it was just obvious is that
Bitcoin is actually really terrible for
privacy it's like awful it's a great
tool for a totalitarian government
because yeah all the transactions on the
Bitcoin blockchain look random ish to us
they're one address paid another and
they go all the way back to 2009 but as
we know well if you can afford to pay
chain alysus or some other big data
aggregator that matches Bitcoin
addresses with real identities through
you know clustering analysis and things
like that you can basically use the
Bitcoin blockchain to D anonymize any
payment and to know everything about the
payment and this is how we did things
like catch Ross Olbrich the guy who is
running the Silk Road and this is how we
also found out that there were two
corrupt government agents in that
investigation who were taking kickbacks
from Ross Ulbricht to not turn him in
because the kickbacks were paid using
Bitcoin on the blockchain actually which
is pretty funny so those are good
examples I guess if you don't think that
there should be online drug markets
those are good examples of Bitcoin being
too public great we were able to stop
Silk Road but there also plenty of bad
examples you'd be basically like if Bank
of America just decided to put a big big
billboard up in Times Square and every
time you transact have a number that
represents you and a number that
represents the person you're paying and
just like that's free for everyone to
see it's not a good way probably to do
privacy so there are new technologies
you guys have talked about CK snarks and
other you know proofs there are mixing
protocols there are ring signatures that
could be incorporated into these
protocols they could be incorporated
into Bitcoin and there's there's long
been talk of that or they could be the
basis of new cryptocurrency is like Z
Cashman arrow the member Wimble protocol
is quite interesting it's being
implemented in Beam and grin and these
will probably lead us to a world where
you can have peer-to-peer payments that
are validated so we know there's no
double spending by an open set of
participants
whoever minds the blockchain but none of
those participants actually learn who
paid who or how much not even a
pseudonym representing those people and
so I think this will work
I think this already works at some small
scale and so these things are coming and
if what you're concerned about is
totalitarian governments and a lack of
financial privacy this is good news if
what you're concerned about is crime and
terrorism this might be very bad news
it's news I think personally free and
open payment systems embody liberal
values because they're open because they
respect privacy and autonomy they don't
put an arbitrary barrier between you and
the person you want to transact with
that doesn't necessarily always obey the
rule of law but it's usually just there
with their own discretion and their own
power making choices for you and so if
that's interesting that's that research
report that we published last February
and we do have sources for things like
the travel ban in that report and with
that I think we're at an hour
[Music]
[Applause]
it's